with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge it was announced
this week that male cheerleaders will
feature as this weekend's Super Bowl in
the US for the first time
Napoleon ginnis and Quinton Perrin will
make history performing alongside their
female colleagues in the LA Rams squad
never one to miss out on an opportunity
to get involved Phil's been working hard
on his prediction tape all morning
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
former squaddies were injured coming
soon to a sports event near you anyway
coming up today Trevor wants MPs to get
on with it Phil thinks we need to
protect our shores
Avila says we need drastic action for
renters and I want top marks for our
kids but first it's Nick G thank you a
question for you how important is or was
your dad to you as you grew up what
might you have learnt from him the
reason I'm asking is after some truly
depressing statistics were published by
Her Majesty's Inspectorate of Prisons
that showed more than half of boys held
in young offender institutions are PME
black or minority ethnic now to give
that context using data from the 2011
census the BMA percentage of the
population is just 14% and while we're
on the subject of figures listen to
these from the Runnymede trust 59
percent of black caribbean children grow
up in lone parent households 9 in 10 of
those families are headed by a woman and
African Caribbean fathers are twice as
likely as white dads to live apart from
their children now I owe my dad more
than words can ever Express which coming
from a journalist is a bit ironic not
for a moment knocking the mums but
perhaps what chance were these young BM
e lads if they've not got a strong dad
in their lives
[Music]
I'm not a hundred percent against what
you're saying Nick I mean like you I had
a strong and rather significant fun but
actually I only lived in my parents
homes child for about four years because
I was in the Caribbean they were here
would it had been different for me if my
father had been where I was I don't know
I think though and I said I think there
is something in what you say I think we
need to be a bit careful here though
those be AME figures and by the way the
term be AME is a thing I hate because it
is obscures truth rather than helps us
understand it and in that 14 percent
there are all sorts of people it
includes people of Indian heritage in
truth the groups that you're talking
about here are black of Caribbean and
some African groups and also Muslims
particularly Pakistani Muslims and the
issue I put to you here is the first
group what you say about being far the
less or far the light family is probably
true but the second group Pakistani
Muslims it is spectacularly not true so
I think simply tracing this to that
cause probably isn't quite enough to get
us to the place where we are June am I
being too simplistic yes and just a
couple of things I think you know
without getting into the stats I think
the statistics are slightly misleading
in the sense that those statistics are
for England and Wales and when you look
at the National picture it's actually 20
percent not 51 percent it's still quite
high but I think really the real problem
here is poverty in general if you look
at what happens when young let me see
that white let's report you yes you do
and if you look around other parts of
the country where you do not have large
PME populations it's white working-class
boys that are in young offenders
institutions and what I'm saying is I
think that there are a number of reasons
of course you have all of the issues
relating to poverty then that's
exacerbated when you add in race
I think what we also have to look at and
I think it is back to your point Trevor
I do think we as a community do have to
start having tough conversations amongst
ourselves within do you mean the black
community Yeah right in relation to this
issue because I find it quite
interesting in the sense that you know
have I ever told you I grew up on the
council and I know a lot of and I know a
lot of boys who decided to take the
wrong path and some who ended up in
young offenders institutions and then
subsequently in prison and when you look
at what happened to the ones that didn't
go down that path the ones that were
kind of on the crossroads it was always
an adult that intervened at some point
there's always an adult that said no we
are not gonna allow that child to be
cheated where would that be a parent
whether that be a family member a
teacher a community leader and I do
think that this is something that we now
need to get organized on and say not on
our watch our parents did not come here
and struggle the way they did for us to
be losing so many of our boys to this I
want to come back to the point at the
very beginning of this role models is
extremely extremely important when I was
a kid I didn't come off the rails quite
inevitably you know to the point that I
was locked up at some stage I spent a
lot of time and it wasn't until that I
actually started turning myself around
so you got dig deep yourself but I'm a
guy called Griff Watkins who's a
commander in the Navy and he gave me a
chance through the whites yes to become
a ski instructor and that's what really
set me on the road to actually thinking
yeah I can achieve something here
because up until that point I've been in
in in children's homes well I didn't
necessarily respect authority and what I
didn't expect it respect authority I
turned to my peers for my respect and my
peers were all doing wrong so I just
joined them of them and I think you know
it's very important that we get
something into these young people an age
where they can actually start looking up
achieving and being rewarded for their
achievements does it just pretty feel go
to athlete you're a bloke I'm a bloke is
it important that a young man has a dad
or a teacher or ski I think it has to be
something that he aspires to be if the
individual doesn't aspire to be a blokey
type that's fine but you need to find a
role model of some description but for
me it had to be a man had to be a strong
man it had to be
I said fill you sort yourself out after
I've had the pleasure of meeting your
family I know family's very important to
you it's very important to me and I
wouldn't disagree with any of what Phil
said I think it's incredibly important
for children to have parents who are
looking out for them or other people in
their community who are looking out for
them I think there is definitely a
specific issue of boys having fathers or
male role model as we sat here and
talked about the numbers that color
specific male teachers well the thing is
that young black men are growing up in a
society where they're massively
underrepresented they look on the TV
they see lines and look the judiciary
the images of black men that are popular
in fact this week there was a campaign
that showed 50 young black men in
hoodies and then revealed what they all
do you know they're lawyers they're
bankers our perception of young black
men is linked to a history where we've
seen them as criminal and out of control
I might just because we're talking and
I'm not denying that it's extremely
important for young men to have to have
fathers or other male figures they can
look up to you there is a history to
behind that and listening to Trevor you
know talk it reminded me of that that a
lot of the black families in this
country were recruited here their
fathers were recruited to come and work
here after the war on their own a lot of
them came alone their families followed
later the British government has played
a role in encouraging the break up of
black families in the patterns of
migration and that's just set a
precedent I hope that is a factor in
looking at why black families are less
likely to be just got a better look
after them you've also got to be able to
relate to them okay it's not good enough
but for instance if you'd have put
somebody I didn't think I could be like
in front of me to motivate me like for
instance if a young black guy needs
someone to look up to as a role model he
might think well I never gonna be like
him because I'm not going to be accepted
looks at him he is an inspiration to yes
I have achieved yes I have been there
done so under preachers oh it's fine
they're the right it's fine you know and
I agree that families are very important
but I do want to challenge the premise
of your argument is one I'm very
familiar with rod little has been free
song oh yeah
right thing about how the reason young
black men are involved in crime is
because they don't have fathers at home
Tony Sewell who's a black commentators
been saying this for a long time if you
look at the real work that's been done
on the criminal justice system it is
much more complicated than that black
boys are more likely to be arrested
charged and imprisoned for the same
offenses as white boys committing the
same offenses the criminal justice
system is not neutral as in every
prejudice and
this has been found over and over again
most recently by the Landry report yeah
and and and it's difficult to deny that
there is bias in the system so it's not
that they're necessarily more criminal
they are being treated more harshly we
can toss it this around endlessly I mean
the government has a view it's given us
a statement they say we are
fundamentally reforming youth custody to
make it safer and more focused on
rehabilitation and as the Chief
Inspector recognizes there have been
encouraging signs of improvement in
safety but we recognize there's still
more to do including tackling
disproportionality in the justice system
and a dedicated team is addressing this
issue head-on reads to me like blah blah
blah let's not get into a sort of
general description of the system let's
think about what we could do now my
point is you could do the numbers look
first of all except the families are
like they are
we could do more to support black women
I think specifically who we know
statistically are more likely to have
two or three jobs now we could do more
specifically to help women in those
households because they haven't got any
time to look after children secondly the
transmission belt from school to prison
are the pupil Referral Units which are a
complete disaster area but a third thing
which I think we could think about
instead of thinking about on what can we
tell families what to do
the one place where a boy could have
more role models currently doesn't is in
schools nine out of ten primary school
teachers are women today I would today
change the law to allow primary school
head teachers to offer men a premium to
teach in primary schools in fact we we
changed we change the 2010 Equality Act
to allow head teachers to choose to
prefer men where the candidates were
equal I'd go further now I'd incentivize
them to put men in primary schools
junior desperate to get better yeah and
I would say in order for all of the
stuff that Trevor has talked about to
happen I believe that the community
needs to get organized and you should
have a conversation a finish let me
finish so I'll give you an example so
remember last year there was
uproar when the sociology textbook said
that Jamaican families were more likely
to be raised by a single parent
household and headed up by a single
parent and basically there was absolute
uproar the community was furious
incensed went nuts in no time that
textbook was rightfully corrected I
believe we need the same on this there's
something that's happened where we've
almost accepted but that this is okay
because if you look at these same boys
here I've just come back from Ghana
these same boys would not be doing this
in Ghana we know these same boys are not
doing this in Jamaica this system has
failed these boys but I also think it's
up to us to say no way explain